sin embargo esta invasión rusa se
remonta a muchos años atrás porque no
comenzó únicamente el 24 de febrero de
2022 Y es que en diciembre de 1991 Rusia
Ucrania y belarus firmaron la disolución
de la unión soviética en consecuencia se
oficializó la independencia de Ucrania
con la elección de León como el primer
presidente del nuevo país quien defendía
una línea soberanista ucraniana y entre
1991 y 1999 la salida de la unión
soviética representó para Ucrania una
severa recesión en la que perdió en 60%
del pib Y tuvo además una hiperinflación
que llegó al 10.000 por ciento en 1993 y
en 1999 comenzó la expansión de la otan
hacia antiguos países soviéticos esto lo
vamos a analizar en unos minutos en
profundidad sin embargo esta comenzó con
la incorporación a la alianza de
antiguos miembros del Pacto de Varsovia
y continuó en 2004 con la entrada de
Bulgaria y Rumanía y las ex repúblicas
soviéticas de Estonia letonia Y lituania
estos tres últimos países basmos a hacer
una aclaración Que luego lo vamos a
utilizar bastante Santiago y es a estos
tres países también se les denominan
como los países bálticos en el 2000
Rusia eligió a Vladimir Putin como su
presidente quien sigue en el poder hasta
el día de hoy entre 2004 y 2005 hubo
acusaciones de fraude electoral en las
elecciones presidenciales de Ucrania y
estas desataron la llamada Revolución
naranja finalmente Se declaró a Víctor
giuchenko como el nuevo presidente del
país quien asumió una línea política
occidental en 2007 el presidente de ruso
Putin pronunció un histórico discurso en
la conferencia de Munich en él atacó la
expansión de la otan hacia el área de
influencia rusa y reprochó las
intenciones hegemónicas de Estados
Unidos esto es un momento clave Santiago
y televidentes porque este ha sido uno
de los argumentos centrales del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin para
comenzar esta reciente invasión a
Ucrania aquel momento se considera
entonces clave en las relaciones
internacionales posguerra fría en 2008
bajo la presidencia de Víctor yuchenco
Ucrania pidió formalmente entrar a la
otan Aunque hoy no es un país miembro de
esta Alianza militar sino un Aliado un
país Aliado Esto va a tener unas
diferencias que luego vamos a analizar y
la crisis económica mundial de ese
entonces confluyó con la recesión
nacional de Ucrania y se prolongó
durante años en 2010 se eligió a Víctor
yanukkovic de la línea Pro rusa vamos
ahora a noviembre del año 2013 el
presidente ucraniano Víctor yanucovi
abandonaba el acuerdo comercial con la
Unión Europea en lo que desencadenó en
las denominadas protestas del
euromaritano un punto clave y de
inflexión para la historia de Ucrania y
lo que vino después estaremos analizando
también todo lo que ocurrió a partir de
aquella Revolución que fue clave para el
país y que condujeron al derrocamiento
de yanukovic Rusia acusa a Estados
Unidos de financiar esas protestas
mientras que vamos ahora a abril del año
2014 porque en medio de la compulsión de
la que hablábamos recién Rusia ingresa
militarmente en crimea y tras realizar
un referendo que no es reconocido de
manera internacional se anexa el de
Finalmente la Península de crimea en ese
mismo contexto Y ante la deriva
prooccidental de kiev buena parte de las
regiones ucranianas prorrusas del donbas
proclaman su independencia como
repúblicas populares de donias y lugans
así comienza la guerra del Don báez
entre las tropas Pro rusas apoyadas por
el Clemen y el ejército u no en mayo de
2014 petrópodos es elegido presidente de
Ucrania con una línea soberanista ese
mismo año y en 2015 se firman los
acuerdos de mins 1 y 2 Entre Rusia y
Ucrania con la intervención de belarus y
de potencias europeas los tratados
fracasan en lo que es conseguir el cese
de la guerra en el don vass el tiempo
avanza y llega a marzo de 2018 cuando la
otan reconoce a Ucrania como país
aspirante a ingresar a la alianza junto
con Georgia abril de 2019 elección de
Vladimir
veronski conocido actor ucraniano como
presidente y él promete devolver el don
vas a Ucrania año 2021 un año clave
también en este conflicto Rusia empieza
a enviar tropas y desplegarlas en la
frontera con Ucrania en este contexto
las potencias occidentales alertan de un
inminente invasión rusa Aunque el clemne
asegura que se trata ejercicios de
entrenamiento militar pueden recordemos
que pedía no integrar Ucrania a la otan
el 21 de febrero de 2022 en un discurso
dirigido a la nación el presidente de
ruso Vladimir Putin reconoce las
autoproclamadas repúblicas populares de
donias y lugans y así llegamos al
comienzo de la más reciente versión de
esta guerra cuando el 24 de febrero de
2022 cerca de 150.000 tropas rusas
invadieron finalmente Ucrania en lo que
Vladimir Putin denominó operación
militar especial